let me get to Brian Hayes the host of
overdrive
that's our Toronto affiliate TSN 10:50
the drive time show from 4:00 to 7:00 he
was at the game last night
how is morale today Brian I think we're
holding up okay Dan it was it was a wild
scene last night and you know Golden
State's a great team they're dynasty
obviously but they squeaked out a win
last night
you know they held control for the
majority of the game but at the end of
the day it's still three two and the
Raptors are seven and two since going
down to nothing against Milwaukee and
three-and-oh on the road a game five in
Milwaukee and games three and four at
Oracle so shockingly it's it's a rarity
up here in Toronto with this sports
history but people are actually feeling
pretty confident today was there a
moment last night where you thought we
have it or a moment last night where you
said we don't have it a half seconds
called that timeout 3:05 left on the
clock and about 30 seconds after play
resumed Kawhi Leonard he he went you
know legend he went on a 10 10 point run
on his own and that building I've been
going there for 20 years I have never
felt that type of electricity course
through that building it was ready to
pop people were going crazy and Steph
Curry misses a three and you could tell
Steph was dejected you know you could
tell he was thinking here we go we're
about to hand over a title and I have no
idea what Nick nurse was doing calling
that timeout and then they come out of
the timeout and clay hits two three
Steph hits a three and Kawhi Leonard
doesn't get another basket and now
they're heading back to Oakland I said
there was five seconds a bad fan
behavior I don't want to blame this on
everybody there obviously but it felt
like you know it's an emotional moment
you're trying to win a championship
you're winning a championship for an
entire country Durant goes down
everybody's excited because they know if
Durant's you know that calf injuries you
know back again hey he's not gonna play
and we got an even better chance the
fans didn't obviously understand the
magnitude of it but they quickly did
your thoughts with the fan reaction did
yeah I think you spot-on Dan I think
there were three chapters
what happened last night with the Durant
injury for starters you've got to go
back to even before the series began
we've been jokingly calling Durant John
wick on our show because he's just the
boogie man that's in the shadows and you
know if he shows up you're in big
trouble so there's been a lot of
trepidation
you know coursing through at the fan
base here knowing who he is and what he
represents it didn't help that he shows
up last night and hits two quick threes
and looks unbelievable in the first
quarter so there was a lot of angst
because of who Durant was and I think
when he originally got injured
the initial pop was people thought Serge
Ibaka got a steal now he didn't Durant
obviously blew out his Achilles or
whatever he did he just kind of let go
of the ball but you're right
I think it was human nature the first
three or four seconds like wow he's down
and that means the Raptors really have a
shot at winning this title that was the
first chapter the second chapter was the
ugliness where people I think understood
the extent of his injury by no means was
the 20,000 people I'm not sure what the
percentage of what of it was in terms of
the crowd but there it was loud enough
you could pick it up and they were
cheering the fact that this guy was
significantly injured
that was the second chapter the third
chapter though was Redemption I think
for Toronto and typically Canadian
because we had to apologize for our
initial reaction and people started
gentle his name and he got a huge
applause as he walked down the tunnel so
I don't think that third chapter has
been brought up enough I understand the
lure and the captivity that comes with
you know booing an injury and obviously
it leads to a lot of debate but there
was a real sense of you know sorrow for
Kevin Durant in the crowd and he did get
a pretty decent chant by the time you
left the building I mentioned this
yesterday in fact I think this was our
poll question for a little while
if I say to the you know the country of
Canada you can have a Raptors
championship or the Maple Leafs win
another Stanley Cup and I said I don't
think this is really a decision or a
choice like this is Canada winning a
championship you know people in Alberta
and Calgary couldn't care less about
Toronto winning a Stanley Cup but it
feels like
you know Canada would be able to embrace
a championship in a sport that they
haven't ever won a championship before
your thoughts on yeah absolutely there
are two quote unquote Canada's teams up
here
it's the Raptors and the Blue Jays
because they're on an island you know
they're the only Canadian teams in the
NBA and Major League Baseball we're in
the NHL you got seven Canadian teams and
the Maple Leafs are so hated by anyone
that isn't a vape relief and I would say
it's like the Yankees and the Cowboys
combined if somehow are you put together
the obnoxiousness of the Yankees fans
and cowboys fans they were dwarfed into
Maple Leaf fans without the success
although the Cowboys haven't had a lot
of success recently either so the rest
of the country it is so polarized do you
either love the Leafs or you vehemently
despise the leaves so I don't think
there's any question if you were if you
were casting votes throughout the
country
the Raptors winning a title would be a
landslide now in Toronto it'd be a very
different story you know obviously the
Raptors are big here but this is a Maple
Leaf town historically and I think it
still will be moving forward but from a
grassroots perspective I've been saying
recently I think if the Raptors can win
a title this will dwarf what Vince
Carter brought to this market and what
Vince Carter represented to basketball
in this country because if they can
actually win the reaction will just be
so jubilant from coast-to-coast do you
care where you get your win if I say
you're winning a championship you care
if it's in Golden State or back in
Toronto well I'm in the content game
then so I say push it seven if we can I
mean if I have that choice you know push
it seven yet you know then you build up
the anxiety a little bit I mean that's
totally selfish as a radio guy just let
her more contest but I think fans
clearly would have said you know last
night and don't make us do this don't
make us go through a game seven
I think Raptors fans are going to be
holding their breath between now and
Thursday night and if they can find a
way to get a win it's never happened you
know the Raptors have
but in the NBA Finals let alone win a
title so quite frankly they could pick
up the game and play in Europe and
people would be fine with it they're
just so excited to be on the verge of
finally winning a title Brian thanks for
joining us we appreciate it all right
Dan thanks and Sabrina Hayes he's the
host of overdrive Hayes noodles in the
o-dog on TSN 10:50 or Toronto affiliate
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]